je vends de la merde
[Rires]
je pense que c'est une ligne brillante
[Musique]
c'est incroyable je suis entouré de
collègues incroyables et nous nous
amusons beaucoup
[Musique]
oui
mon emploi du temps
est un peu plus long parce que
je '  Je me prépare pour un travail que je commence
juste après que nous ayons fini ici, donc je vais
au gymnase à six heures et ensuite je
regarde normalement un film,
nous déjeunons ensemble, nous
avons des réunions, nous regardons un autre film,
préparez-vous pour un tapis ou  un événement
se remettre au maquillage faire l'événement et
recommencer le lendemain donc
entre deux ou quatre films par jour nous
regarderons
[Musique]
c'est la célébration la plus incroyable et la plus
belle de ma forme d'art préférée
donc c'est euh c'est c'est le meilleur
um place to be c'est comme une
énergie explosive d'excitation et de joie
[Musique]
eh bien j'étais un enfant dans un film viking islandais
quand j'avais sept ans avec beaucoup de saleté
dans mes cheveux
et j'étais obsédé et j'ai refusé de
quitter le plateau et je l'ai fait '  Je ne veux pas laver
[Musique]
wow
le grand bleu
était un des premiers films que j'ai découvert
hier j'ai vu un film et une ligne m'a
vraiment marqué
je vends de la merde je
pense que c'est une ligne brillante
[Applaudissements]
je pense que mon plus grand devoir et et  mon
engagement mon mariage avec les films est que
je dois toujours aller
dans un lieu d'honnêteté et ne jamais laisser ma
vanité
conduire
le véhicule mais je dois
essayer de trouver la vérité quoi qu'il arrive
[Musique]
je commence à tourner
une série appelée constellations pour pomme
nous allons tourner pendant six mois à
berlin maroc finlande
merci
[Musique]